Thank you for calling manage light bulb. How may I brighten up your day? You can start by telling me
Why I've got an entire Christmas tree that won't light up
So your lights are properly plugged into an electrical outlet. [oh]
an electrical outlet
All this time I had them plugged into my dogs
I hate my job. Lots of people hate their job man
I failed the bar for the second time which means I got to keep working at the call Center.
I would think that the lucky few who have jobs would be bending over with Gratitude? I...
Are you bending Drew?
I get fired for naked pictures. You are suspended indefinitely. I need your wings
And then humped by a dog in a mask
Yes, Hi I need an officer I was just I don't know I was humped. Yes, he had a black face
Mask! Okay he had a mask not face get it right. Uh-huh
Tell me again why you didn't get her number. Oh, I know exactly where to find her
Star Maker Academy. I'm the only person in this town who can take you right to the top baby
You're so amazing Nick, like like your boobs are heaving and. Hey Nicky. You go here now?
Yeah, oh I just started. I gotta go
What would a little boy like you
do with a woman like me? Unleash your beast.
Ahhh!
That's brilliant. He's the king
Yes, I got the part of the queen
Now look at me and say ooh chelly
Without her job she's gonna need a new pilot
I could be your copilot Drew. We can fly her into some international territory you feel me. What does that even mean?
I need something strange
What're you laughing at?
No I'm not
Do you have a name? Ooh chellini! I feel like I was ridden hard and and put away hot and wet
Nicky you're blowing everybody away. Stay in the moment. Hey get up there.
Oh You wimp. Tell me let you go or I'll hold you like this all day woman. Ow!!
Little handicapped boys, you sick little perverts. What? no! He's just helping me so I could go inside and blow them away. What?!
Star Maker Academy!!!!
You know Jiu-Jitsu?
Okay Nancy, were you able to secure any details? I already told you he had a black face. Mask! It was a mask!